the streets of el paso are empty as the
city's funeral homes
struggle to find space for the dead a
10th morgue truck has been requested
to hold the bodies of people dying
faster
than can be buried unfortunately in my
field uh mortality is a fact
of the profession the numbers i think
the
the numbers of people who are now having
this outcome is what is really being
most
hard for us all of us in the community
to absorb
the population of el paso is 680
thousand
yet more people are hospitalized within
this desert city
than the totals in most u.s states this
parking lot is now a coveted overflow
the downtown convention center is a
field hospital
and doctors and nurses have worked
without rest
calling on colleagues from around the
state for help
we are now basically outsourcing to be
able to do it and i think that's what
on the good side has been fortunate that
we're getting a lot of support
helicopters are now transferring coveted
patients from el paso
to emergency rooms across the state of
texas
to hospitals in san antonio in dallas
and here in houston 1200 kilometers away
doctors here say they are treating not
only those el paso coveted patients
but also bracing for another influx of
their own we got to change that we have
to stop that because
all of us every every person healthcare
team member we are tired we are
exhausted
but doctors say there is no relief in
sight
and that conflicting government orders
are largely to blame
el paso's county executive ordered a
lockdown in late october
only to have the city's mayor refuse to
enforce it
then the conservative state government
of texas said the lockdown was illegal
after which a court reinstated the
lockdown order
every day that the county's order
remains in effect is another day that we
can save lives
this region bordering mexico abounds
with large
multi-generational families previous
infection spikes have followed holiday
gatherings
and thanksgiving is around the corner
andrea cortez is among
15 in her family who contracted kovid
so it was a domino effect um my uncle
got my grandfather my grandfather got my
grandmother
my grandmother got my mom and my uncle
and then my mom got my father and my
siblings in isaac
her grandfather did not survive now he's
among the more than 700 people in el
paso who've died of covid
joined by more souls each day heidi joe
castro
al jazeera houston